how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel cosmic wonder
where we talk about all things relating
to the MCU today cap is back we have
brand new Falcon and the Winter Soldier
news news involving the new Captain
America and some leaked photos that we
got for the series now a lot of
information has come out about the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier series
lately including u.s. agent John Walker
and his story arc and a lot of info
about the first few episodes have been
leaked and they have filmed several
episodes by now so I'll break down
everything that we know and go over this
new propaganda for the new Captain
America if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up-to-date on the MCU
and so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 and
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers so the first
thing we have is a brand new propaganda
poster for the Falcon in the Winter
Soldier series of u.s. agent John Walker
that says cap is back and we can see him
fully dressed in a full Captain America
uniform and as we can see he has his
shield equipped in this poster and as we
can clearly see here it is the exact
same shield that Steve Rogers brought
from his point in time to the present
time to give to Sam now at first we
thought that the government wasn't going
to let Sam be Captain America because of
the scovia cords he did not sided with
the government and was an outlaw however
there has been a recent leak of the
first episode and this leak says that
Sam is actually given the option of
keeping the shield and becoming Captain
America however he has to take the Super
Soldier Serum if he takes the serum he
can become Captain America and the
government will pardon him from all of
his crimes
Sam says that he needs time to think and
while he talks to Bucky Bucky encourages
him not to do it because it's not worth
out living those that he loves and
obviously Bucky would know that and
Captain America would know that as well
Sam goes on to decline the offer to take
the serum and become Captain America and
they give the serum to u.s. agent John
Walker as John Walker undergoes the
serum it is revealed that the serum
allows the recipients mind to be
controlled at first everybody thought
that this new Captain America u.s. agent
John Walker wasn't going to be a good
guy but more of an evil Captain America
well as it turns out we could be very
wrong
it appears that he's actually a very
good person who wants to be Captain
America and do good instead they end up
controlling his mind through the serum
and this is what the government wants
they want to be able to control the new
Captain America because they couldn't
really control Steve Rogers before he
always did what he thought was right
despite what the government said but we
can see here that the government is
really blowing up the new Captain
America we can even see the US Army sign
right on the bottom of the poster and of
course the big cap is back is really
promoting the new Captain America much
like they did during Steve Rogers time
he was kind of the poster boy he was
used to get the morale of the people up
during a time of war but now we're in a
world that is post snap post fan OHS and
the world kind of needs to be
reinvigorated especially since the old
Captain America is gone so that really
trying to get the people going about
this new Captain America so let me know
what you think about this poster and let
me know what you think about the
possibility of u.s. agent John Walker
being controlled by the Super Soldier
Serum that he is given leave all your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
forth